good morning believe nation today's
message is turn your nose into how ten
eyes over to you Lauri Grenier to me an
entrepreneur is somebody who will do
whatever it takes
they're driven they are a type
personalities they it's like they don't
know the word no and that's always been
my mantra I know no knows just how can I
so when I see that person I know that no
matter what even if they have to pivot
you know which is something that happens
maybe this isn't the best idea
but something else is and you're gonna
change it they're still gonna make it
because they have what it takes to be a
successful entrepreneur so I don't
necessarily agree that every
entrepreneur needs to be a type-a
personality but you do need to be
resourceful I think it's one of the most
consistent things about entrepreneurship
is you have to learn to be resourceful
you're gonna get a lot of noes expect it
this is great clip of Sylvester Stallone
where he says that he loves the word no
because it means yes challenge I really
I just love I didn't love it you know I
love being told no it just means yes a
lot of people are afraid of knows a lot
of people are afraid of rejection and
for that reason a lot of people have
great ideas you can do amazing things
you've got this genius thing inside you
that never gets out there because you
got one know
a lot of people turn into the pursue
then because they got there one though
and they never took that bet on
themselves and they have to pull
everybody else down around them and so
what I want you to do is fast forward to
the end of your life think about where
you're at and think about you not
executing this idea think about you
having not taken the action that you
want to take and what that feels like to
have how many years and years and years
and years and years and years and years
and years of regret not having done the
thing that you're supposed to do and
it's a worth it whenever I'm afraid
whenever I get a no whenever I feel down
that's what I try to do if I continue to
live thinking like this imagine what I'm
gonna be when I am 150 looking back on
my life wishing that I had taken one
more shot wishing I'd done a little
little little tiny bit more so expect
knows embrace the nose don't be defeated
by the nose get excited play and no
because after the no if you do it again
and you do it again and you do it again
your eventually gonna get the yes that
you deserve so the question is a today
is I'm curious what is the most
resourceful thing you've ever had to do
in your business leave in the comments
below I'm curious to find out I also
want to give a quick shout out to
Gregory Gomes Gregory thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book your
one word really means a lot to me man
and I hope you're enjoying the read
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot event spresso
more expresso give me go
launched in last 16 years 400 new
products and I have a hundred and
fifteen pens people going through this
now have a lot of options you have
fundraising sites like Kickstarter you
have little online marketplaces like
Etsy do you recommend that people use
these to sort of test out their products
I think a lot of people don't trust
their gut enough I think a lot of people
want somebody to hold their hand through
the process and really that's not the
best way there's no special formula
that's right for every single person you
have to decide do you like Kickstarter
do you feel that's right for you or you
know people have other ways which to do
things so I think it's know your options
it's true though I'm a woman in business
so are you and it's great because
they're different personalities
successful be yourself take care of
business be yourself go for it yeah and
out there but it can be bumpy along the
way any regrets or mistakes that you
feel you've kind of hit through the
years well you know I share certain
bumps that I've had in the book I think
that you know I don't like to look back
there are no mistakes really everything
is a learning lesson and everything
helps you to do better so I talked about
some of the mistakes that I made and it
just helps you to get further along
learn from those mistakes and get
smarter true feeling is this no matter
who you are no matter what age you are
no matter the time in your life if you
have a dream and you have the drive you
can make anything happen and if you are
ever feeling down or feeling like you
can't get over that hump or you just
have a bad day I play this song and you
remember this song okay here it goes
you
[Applause]